bon alors moi je vais je prendre un beau
regard grave et sensible et demandé à
michel audiard ci qui est un grand
romancier michel audiard alors c'est
difficile d'écrire un roman
et puis de faire un peu comme ça l'un
derrière l'autre des films des scénarios
c'est pas du tout le même métier ne
compartimente est d'abord d' un film je
mets en général deux mois pour écrire un
film c'est normal ce qui est bien
d'ailleurs
et je mets 5 ans ou six ans à écrire à
limoux lors la donne ne sont pas du tout
les mêmes
j'explique très lentement très
difficilement leleu si si j'étais pas
plus plus plus doux et enfin je veux
dire c'est le mot qu'il faut employer
pour le cinéma
j'aurais tourné trois films j'en ai fait
des carrières puis trois mois j'aurais
écrit davantage droit parce qu'elle est
un roman c'est tout à fait autre chose
c'est complètement accaparant c'est très
serré puis moi j'écris maintenant mais
maintenant michel heudier remis à
travers vos romans
je retrouve un michel audiard que j'ai
connus comme ça que j'ai la chance de
connaître et qui est quelqu'un de bon de
très sensible et d'assez par moments
déchiré et déchirant et ça ça ne s'est
pas le genre de choses qu'on vous donne
au cinéma dit non parce que d'abord
c'est tout à fait normal parce que dans
un roman en fait je parle de mes
histoires à moi je sais quelques sages
et aucune imagination dans le romanesque
donc j'écris des histoires tout à fait
personnelle au cinéma j'écris les
aventures longe électrique pendant des
années des aventures de gamins là
j'écris des aventures de belmondo je
suis pas concerné je me projette à
travers un personnage là en l'occurrence
mettons puisqu'on parle lui du dinho
l'eau c'était un cambrioleur à fond dans
ce cas vous un homme à femmes
c'est le contraire de moi là je veux
dire je me projette à travers quand on
écrit pour belmondo on sait on sait ce
qu'on va faire
il ya tout de même un style belmondo si
on n'observe pas en commun à 20 heures
beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs sont un peu
de nostalgie sur certains films de
belmont d'elsa pourquoi est ce qui ne
fait plus des films comme ceci cela
notamment il ya la salle de la muse
toujours c'est c'est léon morin prêtre
on dit souvent jean-paul pourquoi fais
tu pues des films comme léon morin tu
commences était quand même fabuleux et
ton physique de 20 cas et où tu avais
l'air d'un prêtre et c'est ce que me dit
jean-paul zoomdici avec une tonsure une
soutane j'avais pas eu l'air de récurer
cheval plus
les acteurs du nom de mami li très très
lucide c'est ce qui fait en ce moment
mon ami qui est très difficile à faire
michel audiard vous dites bon c'est vrai
que vous avez jean gabin et jean paul
belmondo on parlait de l'audiar pendant
des années ah oui bon alors vous vous
les connaissez forcément bien oui gabin
vous le voyez comment qu'on ne vous
écriviez pour lui vous l'imaginiez
commandant vous mais également des
parents très bien mais vous savez quand
on travaille beaucoup avec un acteur
face l avantage de de collaborer assez
fréquemment
c'est qu'on finit par prendre aussi des
choses à l'acteur maga ben roome du tour
du jura gaba parle audiard c'est pas
tout à fait vrai il arrivait que je je
je parle moi ga bas salaires j'utilisais
des mots de gamins l'inde à travers mon
dialogue d expression et gabin vous me
répondriez commence il est également à
ben je vous répondrai pas parce que je
veux dire à la bamba de toute façon les
interviewés la télé âmes fait j'étais
heureux d'hermine
ah bon c'était aussi direct c'est être à
dire à catane malentendu avec lui n'ont
certainement malentendu alors parler
belmondo s'était également les acteurs
les bons acteurs ont un langage commun
vous savez dans la vie vous déjeuner
avec eux
mon temps c'est pas pareil qui avec
belmondo se sont pas simplement des
objets les acteurs moi je les utilise
pas comme des objets je leur prends des
trucs c'est pour ça qu'un acteur avec
lequel il n'y a pas la chimie enfin vous
ça fonctionne pas je ne fais pas un bon
truc j'ai par exemple un très mauvais
souvenir
parce que force citait des grands
acteurs à avoir c'est pas valable j'ai
un très mauvais souvenir d'une
collaboration et yafran inquiétant
immense comédien on ne parlait
absolument pas un homme
moi je pouvais pas faire parler foisnet
dans la vie n'employait pas un mots que
j'emploie c'était dû rendre un mauvais
service qds de lui que lui que lui
imposait un dialoguiste comme moi vers
moi ce que je voulais dire c'est qu'à
travers les scénarios de boue que je
retrouve dans les films que vous que
signer avec le réalisateur
je recherche toujours un petit peu ce
sept autres sept autres vous même que je
connais à travers les romans et
finalement parce que dans vos romans ya
sans cesse des scènes très cocasse oui
mais il ya toujours cette espèce de
frontière sur laquelle on marche un peu
comme sur le fil d'un couteau
on est à mi chemin entre le franc
sourire et une sorte de de réelles
émotions
rami 5 ans pleurer rire aux larmes vous
veillez je veux déjà revient un peu à ça
c'est que dans un lit je suis
directement concerné je raconte un peu
enfin par contre ma vie finale mais bon
alors la vie est quand même fait
beaucoup plus d'emmerdements que deux
explosions de joie donc mes livres ont
un ton forcément un peu un peu amer noir
ou rouge où je mets peut-être des choses
drôles parce qu'il arrive aussi des
choses drôles et ça j'essaie j'essaie de
restituer mais ça peut être drôle
d'ailleurs à l'intérieur de la pire
tragédie
c'est une chose courante mais c'est une
femme depuis ses bases
bahia comme ça qu'on peut raconter cette
histoire je me sens assez pas c'est pas
possible
l'exhibitionniste ce n'est pas tolérable
en était un tueur
je ne trouve pas si le même pattaya pour
parler de soi dans new moon
l'abbé gilles dussault la connaître là
on pourrait faire attaquer mais moi je
me demande de michel audiard si
finalement le cinéma n'a pas un peu
[ __ ] justement votre talent de
romancier moi je pense surtout au
dernier roman enfin je crois que c'est
dernièrement que vous avez écrit lu un
jour et des autres nuits et est-ce que
vous pensez que vous n'auriez pas pu
écrire davantage et parce qu'on vous
reconnaît vraiment un talent de
romancier vous êtes vous êtes poignants
comme zeturf
mais je suis que m'a faite alors qu'on
vous reproche même un peu la facilité
geoffrey magher une oeuvre considérable
si vous voulez très copieux j'aurais pas
été le balzac ou sinon je veux dire
j'aurais peut-être dans le meilleur des
cas remettant une chose mais j'aurais
peut-être été blondin ce que je serai
d'ailleurs très content d'être serge
aurait été le romancier de cinq ou six
livres n'est certainement pas d'une
oeuvre fleuve sera pas j'ai pas le sens
de la fresque d'avoir les méchantes
langues disent que quelquefois vous
faites un peu dans la facilité dans vos
dialogues chili compte le sénat quand
j'ai enfin pu aussi là dessus non pas je
crois j'ai peut-être fait parfois
certains films qui avait un petit
cousinage dents mais ça arrive forcément
parce que vous avez trouvé par exemple
dans le j'ai fait beaucoup de nos grands
mystères île maurice tic ou non bon j'ai
fait par exemple j'ai une série avec
lautner gens qu'on a appelé les tontons
flingueurs les barbouzes tout ça ketty
qu'était du film satirique de voyou ça
mais j'ai fait aussi des vrais films
d'angleterre tous alors il ya forcément
qu il que je fais moi j'aime bien les
imbéciles aussi j'aime beaucoup campent
et des imbéciles alors oui mais
peut-être arrivé une ou deux fois dans
les noms des plaisanteries un peu basse
alors on va c'est fini bien digne les
bains c'est à dire que ça finisse et la
récompense absolu de la malhonnêteté
c'est à dire qu'il aya qui a volé sa
valeur en escouade est scotchant bien
puisque puisque jean-paul dans le coup
mais il finit couvert le combler
d'honneur à ne rien vous cacher et finit
même dans la cour des invalides est fait
chevalier de la légion d'honneur
ah bon et bien on va regarder un extrait
puisqu'un ap ap steve dubé part du
principe qu'une mauvaise action trouve
toujours sa raison sa récompense je
reconnais bien là le mauvais élève peu
dur en diamant suis tout à l'heure alors
si